in part one of this series we learned
about the history of coal its blumenbach
cycle and why coal has been so vital to
Appalachia in part two we'll look at how
the decline of coal has affected the
everyday lives of communities that were
literally built for the industry for a
lot of Americans coal isn't exactly
something that crosses our minds but if
you're an American in Appalachia
especially in Eastern Kentucky coal is
everything calling them a lot of
wonderful things for at legends you know
it gave a lot of people jobs and a roof
over their heads and you know a purpose
I was pretty shocked to find that coal
production there is at its lowest point
in the region since the Great Depression
and nearly 13,000 coal jobs have
disappeared in Kentucky in just the last
eight years when the economy just rocked
here it was the people who are just a
turn they have no idea what to do they
lost their house they lost the cars they
lost their land everything if you drive
around here you'll see cars with license
plate tags that say coal keeps the
lights on and there's such a sense of
pride of we were able to provide for the
nation it's just such a sense of law in
2012 the coal industry took a major
downturn what coal is left is harder to
get you and more expensive to mine the
country is turning to cheaper forms of
energy we've lost about 900 of the best
paying jobs in this county
in the last four years I don't care if
you're in San Francisco if you lose nine
hundred of the best playing job you fill
it you especially feel it in these coal
fields where the economy has been bad
for a number of decades at 34 Jeremy
Brock has had two back surgeries to
treat injuries from the mind a
fourth-generation coal miner cleans
being able to provide for his family
so this region is everything I mean it
it's the only thing I've aged more the
last four years and I had my whole life
as stressful you know maybe I was my god
today and I wanted it was really bad
Jeremy took a $5 an hour pay cut in the
last four years
from 33 to $28 an hour but he considers
himself lucky to still have work he and
his wife thought a gas station store as
a back-up plan for when he's no longer
able to work in the mines but nothing
will pay him like coal did you can't
take a coal miner that is used to making
$70,000 a year and McDonald's making
young 725 an hour at 20 hours a week and
you know the reality is that's not going
to make anyone happy and Eastern
Kentucky's 30% of the population lives
below the poverty line once the site of
fierce labor Wars where unions made
mining jobs safer and more lucrative the
last Union mine was shut down at the end
of 2014 to make matters worse many
miners who lost their jobs didn't work
quite long enough to get a pension and
hardly get to fishing at every 21 years
making any line know a lot of guys hated
not like 15 16 years and that's what you
know it's a bad situation
Rory Farley and his wife Kimberly
Shepherd run a small welding business
they saw the coal industry wreak havoc
on the community in Harlan I mostly
remember the after-effects of my pepper
working in coal mines because he got
black line from the coal mines and
there's a certain cost around here that
a lot of the men have that's the cost
from Blackburn and so I've heard him
suffocated essentially in front of me
for like 25 years because it's a really
slow thing
Laurie couldn't plan a job despite his
bachelor's degree so he does
and start his own welding business last
year with Kimberly joined but starting a
small business in Eastern Kentucky is no
easy thing it takes us an hour and a
half to get to the interstate from here
so it's really tough if we need to get
somewhere in the shop for our daughter
school clothes or like I said you know
if I have to go to buy a piece of
equipment the closest welding shops over
an hour and a half from here with the
odds so high against them
I wondered why Kimberly and Rory decided
to make a go of it in Harlan when you
don't have money you can hiccup and
leave it like I think we sit down one
time and figure that just to go from
here to Lexington would have cost us
over $3,600 just the money loss and
we're also not having an apartment so I
mean if you don't have $3,600 for these
I would have been half of a yearly
income for me essentially at the time
you know a lot of people did leave by
the thousands in fact eleven hundred
people leave Eastern Kentucky every year
and the death rate is now higher than
the birth rate but some aren't ready to
say goodbye to coal the only economy
they've known I still train people right
now in the building behind me they're
training people that are working to -
that don't exist how am I getting like
that for like six weeks and I get
backlash for saying that's it
whatever - secures I mean I don't answer
it's hard to watch people walk in that
building to go training for a job that's
not going to be there when they're done
during his presidential campaign Donald
Trump promised to bring back Kol job but
from what we heard from people in the
region no politician would be able to
make things like they were that's what
Rachel McCall please
you know he was gonna bring told back to
coal country
I guess I say I'm not sharpest knife in
the drawer but a lot of this stuff
depends on the economy there's not a
need for coal you know there's there's
not gonna be jobs
I vote for Trump where he's not going
he's not a matte shine long like he's
traded there forever I praise e Trump
said he's going to bring back Kol I
don't believe through many it's not
about some politician coming in and
fixing things it's about the people of
Appalachia working to get Appalachia
back on its own two feet without the
coal industry during our trip to Eastern
Kentucky we learned that there is a way
that a flasher can get on and succeed
without the coal industry so in the next
video we'll need some people who are
trying to make that happen
including one couple who left their
corporate jobs in the city to move to a
small town of 2,000 people to try to
help rebuild it